bernard reynès pour le groupe l'est
républicain ma question s'adresse à
monsieur mini's l'intérieur le 13
novembre dernier au soir des terribles
attentats qui ont endeuillé paris omar
ismail mostefaï est l'un des terroristes
qui pénètrent dans l'enceinte du
bataclan pour cause est l'un des plus
grands massacres de l'histoire de notre
pays
né en banlieue parisienne il n'était
connu que pour des petits délits
son casier judiciaire faisait mention de
huit condamnations entre 2004 2008 sans
aucune incarcération au stade de france
au bataclan mais aussi lors des drames
de janvier dernier le parcours de ces
assaillants français radicaliser et
toujours marqué j'allais dire
inexorablement marqué en amont par des
faits de petite délinquance des faits
comme autant de signaux dallaire qui
force est de constater n'ont pas été
suffisamment prises en compte par la
justice
cela démontre incontestablement une
faille dans la prise en charge et le
suivi de ces jeunes dont certains faute
d'une véritable détection tombe dans la
délinquance de droit commun puis dans
l'islamisme radical et le terrorisme ne
voyait ne voyons donc bien nous voyons
donc bien que la prévention de la
délinquance et la prévention du
radicalisme religieux sont intimement
liés monsieur le ministre la loi de mars
2007 positionne le maire comme animateur
essentiel est le pivot dans la
prévention de la délinquance en
partenariat khl procureur les chefs
d'établissements les travailleurs
sociaux les forces de l'ordre cette
collégialité autour du maire permet de
détecter au plus tôt
le comportement déviant deux jeunes
individus dans un processus de
radicalisation
il est temps d'utiliser cette loi et
même de la renforcer pour donner plus de
pouvoir au maire et à sa police
municipale
monsieur le ministre ma question est
simple quand allez vous réaffirmer le
rôle du maire dans sa fonction de chef
de file sur la prévention la délinquance
est donc comme un acteur majeur de la
détection le plus en amont possible et
dérive radicale chez certains jeunes
si monsieur le député la parole et à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le député je partage en tout
point le constat que vous faites est la
préoccupation que vous exprimez
concernant le rôle des maires à tel
point que avant que les attentats du
mois de janvier et ceux d'il ya dix
jours ne se produise nous avions pris
avec la garde des sceaux à la demande du
premier ministre
une directive une circulaire celle du 29
avril 2014 par laquelle nous organisions
sur l'ensemble des territoires
le travail en commun d administration
dépendant de l'état de la justice
puisque le dispositif est coprésidé par
le préfet le procureur de la république
et nous avions souhaité aussi nous avons
souhaité que les collectivités locales
et notamment les collectivités locales
départementales soit associé à cette
réflexion les préfets ont reçu comme les
procureurs de la république des
instructions permettant la mobilisation
des maires notamment sur le périmètre
des zones de sécurité prioritaires où la
petite délinquance parfois conduit à des
phénomènes de radicalisation qui peuvent
aller jusqu'au basculement dans le
terrorisme
notre intention est de procéder au
renforcement de la relation entre l'état
et les maires
c'est le sens de l' échange que j'ai eu
avec françois baroin la semaine dernière
dans des directions extrêmement précise
que je veux évoquer de nouveau devant la
représentation nationale
d'abord mieux articuler les polices
municipales et les polices nationales
des propositions ont été faites à
l'occasion de la discussion de la fin de
la semaine sur l'état d'urgence par le
président de l'association des polices
municipales présent estrosi nous allons
nous revoir autour de françois barois
pour voir les conditions dans lesquelles
sur l'armement sur l'egypte protection
sur l'accès aux fichiers
nous optimisons les dispositifs
existants deuxièmement nous avons
augmenté de 10,7 millions les fonds du
fonds interministériel de prévention de
la délinquance pour accompagner les
collectivités locales dans les
initiatives de déradicalisation qu'elles
peuvent prendre
et troisièmement nous allons renforcer
l'action commune au sein des zones de
sécurité prioritaire
de manière à mieux agir à la fois contre
la petite délinquance et contre
l'article ainsi monsieur le ministre la
parole est un monsieur jean pierre